- So any parent that
is listening to this
has probably heard about
the Scholastic or Highlights
book fairs. Right?
This is supposedly, you know,
oh, clean nonpolitical content
that is brought
into schools, right?
You see them in
every private school
and every public school.
Scholastic is as
leftist as it gets,
if you're calling PragerU
curriculum right wing
then Scholastic and Highlights
have fallen off the cliff
of leftism.
Take a look at this one.
So this is a book
that they've given,
Scholastic has given
an award to, okay.
This book called Melissa is
supposedly for fifth and sixth
grade literacy classes.
If you look at the
actual text in there,
you'll see that it's probably
written for somebody who can
read at the level of
third and fourth grade.
Melissa is a book about a
boy that has transitioned
into being a girl and you know,
it basically celebrates
this gender fluidity concept
that they're trying to
push on our children.
You wanna tell me
that this is not laced
with political propaganda,
to call PragerU curriculum,
find anything from
PragerU kids and tell me
that it's as extreme as
this left wing propaganda.
But you know what media
outlets are highlighting
that this type of product is
a complete extreme left wing.
So, you know, parents
are upset, rightfully so,
and we need our own
representation in our schools.
And that is what PragerU
is effectively doing.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is the CE of PragerU.
Marissa Streit, Marissa from
California, Los Angeles.
How are you?
- It's great to be here.
- You see how I kind
of stuck it to you?
'Cause we used to have a lot
of dinners in Los Angeles
and now I'm in the
free state of Florida.
- Yes, yes.
- And I know you're there and
there's no sense in overly
drumming you over
the head with it,
and yet I still feel
the need to do it.
- That is true. And here I
am delivering a gift for you
and your kids for a better
education in Florida.
So there you go.
- You absolutely are.
So, we covered it.
We covered it on
my show this week.
So let's just dive
right into it.
Well, why don't I
let you lay it out.
PragerU is now going to be
part of the Florida curriculum
for young people.
Go from there.
- Yeah, so we are now
a Florida State approved vendor,
which means that teachers
can use PragerU turnkey
lesson plans in the classrooms,
which really should not
be that controversial
because our content is wholesome
and actually represents
what parents hope to see
in kids' schools.
And you know, this seems
to be a trend where Florida
seems to lead the way in doing
what it is that Americans
actually want and
what's good for kids.
So yeah, congratulations
to all of those in Florida
who now will start
seeing PragerU content
in their classrooms.
- In case you needed
one more thing
for me to needle you on in
moving to Florida yourself,
now you literally are creating
content for our children.
- There you go.
There you go. Yeah.
- How did this
even come to pass?
I wanna get into some of
the specifics of what types
of things will be being taught
and some of the
controversy around it,
which is mostly
nonsensical of course,
but how did this even happen?
- Yeah, it's actually
an amazing story.
So a couple of years ago
we launched PragerU Kids
because we realized that
America needs content
for children that is
actually educational,
that actually teaches them
about American history
and civics and even
financial literacy.
And so we had originally a
direct to consumer market
where we had an OTT,
we had our website
and parents would come
onto our properties
and download content and
show it to their children.
Well, a couple of
years ago we realized
that we can create another
journey for our consumer,
and that is actually
through the schools.
And so, you know, we
spoke to Manny Diaz,
who's the education
state commissioner,
we bumped into him one time
and he said, oh my gosh,
my kids absolutely
love PragerU kids.
We show it at home all the time.
How do we bring this
service to other Floridians?
And we, you know, we
talked, we strategized
and we realized that PragerU
can really fill in a vacuum
in the market because,
you know, teachers are not
being given resources that
represent what America wants.
They don't, they are given
resources that are laced
with leftism.
They're laced with
critical race theory.
And while we're winning,
we have a lot of victories.
We're winning school
boards, we're willing,
we're winning governors
and representatives
that do represent the public,
that do represent a
patriotic America.
The problem is that there isn't
enough turnkey lesson plans
for teachers to actually use.
And so even if we have
these great victories
of folks sitting on boards,
or even finding normal teachers
that are willing to teach
what should be taught,
they also need resources.
And so PragerU is stepping
into this vacuum to produce
the resources that
the communities,
whether it's the teachers
or the parents want.
And what's really great, I
think about the curriculum
that we make, or the
content that we make,
is that the teachers
can use the content,
but they can also provide it
to the parents to use at home.
We call it the
flipped classroom.
And so if a child is
watching a video at home,
there is no secrecy.
They can watch that video in
school and vice versa, right?
So the teacher can
show the videos
and they can say to the parents,
if you want to
have reinforcement,
if you wanna know what's
happening in the classroom,
you can go into the website
and see exactly what's being
taught in school.
No more gaslighting.
- Man. I mean, that
is completely counter
to what is going on,
certainly in California
and many other blue states.
But I like a phrase
you just said,
they're laced with leftism.
Because when I heard about this
that you guys were gonna be
working with the
state of Florida,
I think I saw a tweet
from PragerU about it.
So then I did a little
Google news search
and of course all
the usual hit pieces
and nonsense come out.
The first one I saw was
from Miami New Times,
and this is what we
referenced on the show
a couple days ago.
I just thought I'd
read one paragraph,
just a couple sentences to you,
'cause it's just so perfect.
"PragerU, a conservative
nonprofit often criticized
for downplaying systemic racism
and promoting anti-immigrant
theories, announced today
that Florida is quote, the
first state to officially
approve PragerU as an
educational vendor."
Now it's funny 'cause that
doesn't sound that evil
except they are immediately
often criticized for downplaying
systemic racism as if it exists
just because they're saying
it and promoting
anti-immigrant theories,
which I've never
heard on PragerU.
I've heard things about
actually having a border
that matters, but nothing
about anti-immigrant.
But you're used to this
sort of thing, I suspect.
- Yeah, I mean, you
say often criticized,
often criticized by whom?
The teacher's unions who
don't care about our kids
and don't, they actually
don't even care about parents.
They only care about their
own money and their own power.
And so yeah, sure.
The NEA and the AFD
criticize us all the time,
except, you know, they have
had so much power and influence
over America's education system
that now they're criticizing
us because frankly,
they're scared.
They know that we
represent the majority
of what Americans want,
and they have too long,
had so much control over
our education system.
They're calling our
content political.
Our whole point is to actually
bring Americanism and truth
to classrooms while they
are using curriculum.
I'm gonna give you a couple of
examples of the type of stuff
that they celebrate.
- Oh. God, you're not
gonna show me one
of these naked books
that they've got in.
- Yes.
I'm gonna show you these books.
So any parent that is listening
to this has probably heard
about the Scholastic or
Highlights book fairs, right?
This is supposedly, you
know, oh, clean non-political
content that is brought
into schools, right?
You see them in
every private school
and every public school.
Scholastic is as
leftist as it gets
if you are calling PragerU
curriculum right wing.
Then Scholastic and Highlights
has have fallen off the cliff
of leftism.
Take a look at this one.
So this is a book
that they've given,
Scholastic has given
an award to, okay,
this book called Melissa
is supposedly for fifth
and sixth grade
literacy classes.
If you look at the
actual text in there,
you'll see that it's
probably written for somebody
who can read at the level
of third and fourth grade.
Melissa is a book about a
boy that has transitioned
into being a girl.
And, you know, it basically
celebrates this gender fluidity
concept that they're trying
to push on our children.
You wanna tell me
that this is not laced
with political propaganda?
To call PragerU curriculum,
find anything from PragerU kids
and tell me that it's as extreme
as this left wing propaganda.
But you know, what media
outlets are highlighting
that this type of product is
a complete extreme left wing.
So, you know, parents
are upset, rightfully so,
and we need our own
representation in our schools.
And that is what PragerU
you is effectively doing.
- You wanna show me one more
of these lefty propaganda books?
I feel, feel you have
a whole library there.
- I have a library.
I mean, we can
spend the whole day
because really there's, you
know, Palestinian Causes, right?
There's like, you gotta really
try to figure out why America
is teaching, you know,
this kind of stuff.
But I have a whole list of it,
and I'm sure any parent
listening has their own list
of this kind of stuff.
You know, the thing
is that up until now,
the education system of
America has been represented
by the teachers unions
who have represented
left-wing propaganda and
PragerU is representing
the parents of America.
We are not paid by any
sort of political group
that is pushing this
kind of, you know,
political roping
of our children.
And so, you know, yeah,
sure they're upset
and because of that
they're gonna lie about us.
But at the end of the day,
we're not misleading
and problematic.
We're actually very transparent
about what we stand for,
unlike these other
curriculum makers.
- Right. So first off,
what ages are you guys
gonna be writing curriculum for
or working on the
curriculum for?
- Yeah, so our
partnership with Florida
actually starts
from kindergarten.
And so we have content
from kindergarten
all the way through college
with our five minute videos.
- Wow. So, and this is all
gonna be new stuff, old stuff,
blend of the things
that we know of you guys
is a little Dave
Rubin left the left,
gonna make it in there.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, we're hoping
that we'll be in there.
Look, we believe in
education choice.
So at the end of the day,
it's up to the schools
to choose what kind of
content they wanna use.
We are providing
them with the tools
so they can be more successful.
But at the end of the day, if
they stumble upon why I left
the left with Dave
Rubin and they realize
that it's something worth
bringing into the schools,
at least we're protecting
the teachers from being fired
from using those videos.
And we're providing them
these turnkey lesson plans
that they can use.
Ultimately, it's up to
the communities to decide
what it is that they wanna
use from our, you know,
vast library of content.
And the next steps for us is
not just to work with Florida,
we're working with Texas,
we're working with additional
states around the country.
You know, Florida is
taking the first step
because they're
brave for our people.
But yes, you'll see
a lot more content
and much of it is gonna echo
some of the state standards
that are already out there.
And so if Florida has
state standards to teach
certain things, we're
reading through it
and we're developing some
of this content together
with the states.
- Even though you guys have
been in this for a while
and you personally for a while,
and you've dealt with
the censorship and
the big tech stuff,
and you guys have sued
Google and all of that stuff,
are you shocked at the way that
the schools have gone about
so much of this?
Meaning not just that
they're pushing these books,
but the way they hide it
from parents specifically,
like there's almost
an apparatus in place.
It's not just, we're gonna
let you read this stuff,
we're also gonna let you read
it, call you a different name
and not tell the parent.
That's a whole different level
than just dealing with it
at a curriculum level.
- Yeah, I mean, every single
day working in this field,
honestly shocks me.
You know, Randy Weingarten,
who really is the union boss
of the AFT, the American
Federation of Teachers,
I don't know if you know this,
but she doesn't even
have kids, right?
- I did not know that.
But that might be why she
thinks everyone else's kids
are hers.
- Becky Pringle,
who's the union boss,
head of the largest
teacher's unions, the NEA,
she doesn't have kids either.
- Wow, that's wild,
actually. Really.
- You know, it's pretty
wild, every day shocks me.
Now, Randy Weingart is
working with President Biden
on some task force,
an extension of the Department
of Homeland Security.
And so those of us parents
who are really upset that they
put the FBI on us when
we went to school boards
and protested against
the lockdowns,
now we're even more concerned,
what is going on here.
You have the teachers
unions that own,
effectively they own the
Department of Education,
which you probably already
know that this department
needs to be dismantled because
here our taxpayer dollars
are going into funding
an organization
that doesn't care
about our children.
On top of that, now
you have Randy involved
with the Department
of Homeland Security.
On top of that, they're
working with News Guard,
which I know already got you
in trouble for saying the word
News Guard on your show. Right.
- Just real quick, for
people that don't remember.
Last time you were on the show,
maybe like four months ago,
you said something about
News Guard on a Friday,
on the next Monday, I had
an email from News Guard
in my inbox saying, we are
now looking into your show.
Which then I blew up publicly
and apparently I
scared them off,
but God only knows what
they're working on.
But thank you again for that.
- I was afraid that
you're, you know, Dave,
I was afraid that you actually
won't let me back because,
you know, attacking
the teachers.
Attacking the teacher's
unions is a scary thing.
Many, many people have said
to me, are you sure Marissa,
that you're willing
to take this on?
Because they are a very,
very powerful group.
And so, look at my shirt.
I'm the mama bear. Right?
That's what I care about.
At the end of the day, what
am I gonna do with my life
and my time, if not to
protect America's kids?
But yes, every single
day shocked me,
shocks me when
I'm in this field.
Because how do we have people
that have so much power
and so much influence
over our children,
yet everybody is afraid to
push against them. Right?
Yet they are just amassing
more and more power
while they're not bringing any
result, any positive results
for our kids.
It is pretty shocking.
But, you know, I also
think that America,
the timing for what
we are doing right now
could not be any better.
I think that there are many
people like Governor DeSantis
and Manny Diaz and other
states, which you know,
will announce in the next
few weeks are realizing that
the true representation of
Americans is one that actually
advocates for children
and students and families
and not union bosses.
- So since I know you and
Noah and your kids personally,
and since you're wearing a
shirt that says Mama Bear,
does it say, Mama Bear,
I didn't see Bear.
- Yeah, the bear is in my heart.
- Oh. The bear is in your heart.
- I'm the bear.
- Oh, that's the point.
Okay, got it. Got it.
Can you talk a little
bit about like,
what it's like to live,
you live in La, blue place,
I've heard you talk about
what it's been like.
Well, but I don't mean it,
about the crime and the homeless
and the drugs and all that.
I mean literally
about the kids stuff.
We'll stick with that.
Just trying to get your kids
in a place where they will not
be infected by this stuff.
'Cause it's great that you
guys will hit up Florida
and Texas and some of
these other places,
but obviously a place
like Cali and New York,
they're not gonna be
open to these ideas
and parents there just
don't know what to do.
- Yeah, you know, I think
it actually for parents
who live in states like
California and New York,
it's even more of a wake
up call, but not the only,
we're not the only ones who
have to wake up to the issue
that separating the
education of our children
from our households
is a bad thing.
I mean, parents have
been taught that our job
is to bathe our kids, feed
them, maybe take them to sports,
make sure that they get a good
night's sleep and, you know,
rinse and repeat.
Not be they, we have been
asked to not be involved
in the education of our kids.
And if you live in a
place like California,
you realize even more
so how important it is
that you are involved in the
education of your children.
If a teacher tells you that
they're not sending homework
home or you don't need to
be involved in what it is
that they're learning,
or if you feel like you're
being gaslit, right?
Which is what many
parents are experiencing,
by the way, not
just in California.
This is happening also in
Florida and in Nashville, right?
We are actually, we
need to be both on alert
and we need to take back
the education of our kids.
And I'm not saying do not
send your kids to school.
I understand that not every
parent can homeschool.
Noah and I cannot homeschool.
We do send our kids to school,
but we are very, very involved.
We ask a lot of questions.
We are involved in
inoculating them and educating
and talking to them.
This is why we've made
these short sound bites,
these short little vignettes,
these videos that you can,
you know, sit around
the dinner table
and have these conversations
with your children.
So that when they go up
to school or to the mall
or they even watch
Barbie, God forbid, right?
You know how to have
these conversations
with your children.
And you know, I think
that our guard is up
when you live in a state like
the state that I'm living in.
But we need to really set
an example for other parents
around the country that all
of our guard needs to be up
when it comes to
our kids everywhere.
And so it's definitely
difficult to raise kids
in California, but I
think that it reminds us
of how important it is
that we don't, you know,
forfeit the education
of our children.
- I saw in some of the articles
that were criticizing you,
people were saying, but
PragerU is not accredited.
They're not accredited,
which to me,
when I hear someone's
not accredited,
probably doing
something decent, right?
Jordan Peterson Academy,
the Peterson Academy
not accredited.
I'm pretty sure people
are learning over there
and learning what PragerU,
but can you talk a little
bit about accreditation?
And why people should perhaps
not be so obsessed by it.
- Right, if you think about it,
actually the word accredited
should be synonymous with
the word controlled, right?
And so that is what these
accreditation institutions
have become.
They have been able to
really control information.
And so if you don't want to
be controlled by, you know,
big government or you know,
big advertisers, I mean,
remember there are a lot
of advertisers in the world
of education as well,
not to mention, you know,
political agendas.
If you don't want the control,
then you actually may
wanna look for institutions
that are not accredited
because then you can actually
get truth and unfiltered
and uncontrolled.
And that has really been
our motive here at PragerU
is not necessarily
to be accredited,
but I'll let you in
on a little secret.
There is a state that we
are working with right now,
and I can't name it yet
because I don't want it
to get messed up,
where kids can get actual
school credit for finishing
certain modules with PragerU.
And so let's take the example
of our financial
literacy module,
where you can actually acquire
a lot of skills and education
through finishing our
financial literacy videos
and completing the checking
for understanding unit.
If you finish the unit and you
submit that to your school,
the state is actually
gonna give school credit,
high school credit
to kids who do that.
Now it, again, we're not
an accredited institution,
but people can get credit
for watching PragerU videos
in high school.
- How do you make sure
it doesn't get political?
Because in, you know, I
know you don't want to
indoctrinate these kids.
You want them to know the
truth and that will certainly
be connected to the stuff
that you're giving them.
But at some point it then leads
to political thoughts obviously.
So how do you make sure
you don't just become
the polar opposite of what
the left is doing right now?
- You know, I think that
when it's the right time
for kids to start
talking about, you know,
these kinds of political issues,
then we encourage debate.
And essentially what we
would say is that, you know,
sixth or seventh grade listen
to both products, right?
We know that there's a
product called CNN 10
in many schools across America.
This is news provided by CNN
in virtually every classroom
across the United States, right?
There is no debate in
American schools right now.
If you want real
debate, then have both,
and I'm not saying take
CNN 10 out of schools,
I'm just saying, well, if
you're watching CNN 10,
then also watch the
PragerU products
and allow the child
to listen to both
and, you know, foster
critical thinking
so that they can ultimately
make their own decisions.
You see we are not the ones
who are calling to boycotts
Scholastic and CNN 10.
I'm not calling for that.
I'm calling to have an even
playing field in the mind
of American kids.
Watch both, have
discussions at home,
make sure that your parents
are involved as well,
and then ultimately
make your own decisions.
But the fact that we are
not allowed to enter America
schools because they have
put a gate in front of
our education system that
in my opinion is political
indoctrination and that is
what we're advocating against.
Just allow us to show up as
well so people can make their
own decisions.
- What do you think the
indoctrination is doing
to these kids beyond
like the obvious stuff
that a lot of kids now
are suddenly confused
about their gender
identity or something.
I mean, as you know, we
have two baby boys here,
and I think about it every day.
I'm like, man, their
world is so open.
It is so my responsibility
to fill them up
with as much of the
right stuff as possible.
So the bad stuff doesn't get in.
I can't imagine being a
parent of a five year old,
finding out that your kid
suddenly is confused about all
of this stuff.
Like I mean it sort of more
socially than educationally.
What do you think is
happening with kids right now?
- I mean, you're
seeing depression rates
at an all time high.
I mean, you're talking
about five-year-olds
and obviously with
five-year-olds or
seven year olds,
it's very difficult when
they're sexualized early
and confused early.
But by the time
they reach age 15,
I mean, really it's horrendous.
It's either depression, body
dysphoria, body dysmorphia,
you know, also kids who don't
have something to stand on,
actual, real
education to stand on,
that vacuum is filled
up in other ways.
You know, the anxiety
is an all time high.
Kids don't even know
how to date anymore
because there's all
of that confusion.
And then if you look really
downstream employers, like,
we have 150 employees
working for PragerU
and we are getting the
cream of the crop here,
but talk to other CEOs.
What does America's
workforce look like right now
when we have kids who have
been taught from kindergarten
through 12th grade and
oftentimes post-grad
that you know, they're
victims that, you know,
the system is set
up against them,
that, you know, they should
just do what feels good
to them all the time.
This stuff is what's laced.
This is the leftism that
I think is dangerous,
that is actually laced
in school curriculum.
That is what scares me.
I don't want my child to be
taught that they're a victim.
I don't want my child to
be taught that America
is a horrible place
to grow up in.
I mean, that alone
creates anxiety, right?
Its like, oh, you
have no future.
You're living in a
horrible country.
All of those kinds of ideologies
that are in our, you know,
in our classrooms
are frankly scary.
And we do need to find a way
to inoculate our children
against the culture,
the media, the schools
that are teaching our kids
how to not be successful.
That to me is even more scary
than the fact that they,
you know, can't do math
or can't read properly.
Is this, you know, brain mush
that they're experiencing.
And then you take math
of course, and, you know,
they're hearing that math
is racist and you know,
I mean that that
really is terrible.
Like, you know, you think
that Russia and China
and the other countries
that we're competing against
are teaching this kind of
garbage to their kids? No.
- TikTok in China
is very different
than TikTok in
the United States.
I should note, since you
mentioned your 150 employees,
that two of my employees
are former PragerU people
and they have done a
bang up job over here,
which is obviously
indicative of what you guys
do over there.
And you also gave it the
blessing to allow them to come
to me, which does a little
something about you as a CEO.
We can send these people, the
good people to PragerU kids
if they wanna see some of the
stuff that kids in Florida
will be learning.
- Yeah. Go to PragerU,
what I really recommend
for all families is to
download the PragerU app.
Either, you know, if
your kids have an iPad,
I'm sure many do, or you can
download it onto your smart TV
onto your phone.
And instead of them
watching YouTube.
Have them watch
PragerU and you know,
you can trust the content
to know that it's
wholesome and safe.
- I know you're not
doing toddler stuff,
but you know about
this Miss Rachel lady.
Half my day is watching
Miss Rachel now.
- Yeah. We'll get
there, we'll get there,
we'll do music and toddler
stuff and we'll get there.
- Oh, watch out Miss Rachel.
Marissa, it has been
a pleasure as always,
and we'll link to
everything right down below.
- Thank you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full
interviews on a variety
of topics, watch our
full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.